This is Timor-Leste.
If you, dear viewer, were born before May
20th, 2002, then congratulations, you are
older than this country — the fifth-youngest
internationally-recognized sovereign nation.
At 19 years old, it would qualify as a legal
adult in some parts of the world.
Timor-Leste, meaning “East East” in Malay
and Portuguese — is situated in south southeast
Asia — just above Australia.
Its closest neighbor, however, is Indonesia,
with whom it shares half the island of Timor
— about the size of Hawai’i.
But, just to complicate things, part of its
territory is governed as a detached Special
Administrative Region inside Indonesia.
Like many young, developing nations, Timor-Leste
is poor.
Really poor.
Approximately 40% of the population is unable
to afford daily necessities and over half
of all children under the age of five are
developmentally stunted — more than all
but 2 other countries.
The problem is essentially this: To live longer,
happier lives, the country needs more and
better jobs.
Currently, only about 25% of the working-age
population is employed in the formal economy.
The rest either can’t find work or are preoccupied
with farming or basic household duties.
Now, to get jobs, it needs some form of investment.
And to get investment, it would need some
kind of resource worthy of extraction.
And, in fact, it does.
As of 2020, Timor-Leste’s GDP was $1.8 billion.
And yet just 90-miles off its coast sits somewhere
between twenty and fifty billion dollars — depending
on prices — worth of oil and liquid petroleum
gas.
This is not a new discovery.
Its existence has been known to the world
for nearly fifty years.
There’s just one tiny problem...
Sponsored by CuriosityStream and Nebula — where
you can watch the bonus video which accompanies
this one for just $15 bucks a year.
Timor-Leste’s path to independence was…
tumultuous, to say the least.
In 1998, after twenty years of violent Indonesian
occupation in which hundreds of thousands
were killed, pro-democracy protests led to
the resignation of its president, Suharto.
His replacement was more amenable to change,
or, at least its appearance, and in 1999,
called a referendum on independence.
Between becoming a special, autonomous region
of Indonesia, and forming a new, independent
country, an overwhelming majority of the 450,000
voters — 78% — chose the latter.
Not expecting this outcome and having only
wished to use the vote to win legitimacy,
Indonesia began a new campaign of total destruction.
During this time of UN-maintained limbo, nearly
all of the region’s infrastructure was burned
to the ground and its people forcibly shipped
to the western, Indonesian side.
By the time of formal independence in 2002,
Timor-Leste had, at last, a strong, healthy
democracy, and… not much else.
Its newfound freedom had truly cost it everything.
There was, perhaps, only one silver lining.
It had one thing few other young nations do:
oil.
Lots of it.
And the timing could not have been better.
This is a graph of global oil prices.
Its first and only developed oil field, Bayu
Undan, was built here, in 2004, when construction
costs were at their lowest.
And this is when Bayu Undan reached peak production,
around 70 million barrels a year — precisely
when oil prices reached their highest ever
on record.
Because of this, fragile, young Tim or-Leste’s
sovereign wealth fund was the only one to
survive the 2008 financial crisis unscathed.
It was an amazing stroke of luck for the place
that needed it the most.
But no oil field lasts forever.
Oil revenue peaked in 2012 at $3.56 billion
and has been in sharp decline since.
Now this would be concerning — disastrous,
even — for any country.
But for Timor-Leste, this could be existential.
As the 2nd most oil-dependent country on Earth,
90% of its public revenue and 80% of its GDP
comes from this one resource.
None of this money, however, has translated
into long-term development.
Its economy has not fundamentally changed
despite these riches.
Between 2014 and 18, the number of private
employees fell by 15%, despite the working-age
population increasing by 10%.
Instead, oil has only delayed the inevitable.
Meanwhile, the money is rapidly running out.
This is the amount of oil money the government
could spend sustainably — that is, only
the interest.
And this is how much it is spending.
If trends continue, experts predict the money
will be all gone in 10-15 years.
Which brings us to the Greater Sunrise Field
— five trillion cubic feet of gas and 225
million barrels of condensate worth $50 billion
southeast of Timor-Leste.
Although located in deeper water, Greater
Sunrise is actually closer than Bayu-Undan.
And this time the country has a plan to convert
this temporary windfall into lasting prosperity.
The difference is that this time the oil will
be processed onshore, creating local jobs
and, in theory, developing the wider economy.
The “Tasi Mane” project, as it’s known,
involves converting over a thousand hectares
of agricultural land across three towns into
interconnected, petroleum processing facilities.
If managed well, this could be step one on
the path to Timor-Leste’s development — a
pivotal turning point for the entire country.
So what, exactly, is the problem?
It all started with oysters.
As the world began figuring out who owned
which parts of the ocean, Australia’s primary
concern was preventing Japanese fishermen
from harvesting oysters off its Northern coast.
The big debate, at the time, was: Should maritime
boundaries be drawn halfway between two countries,
or following the natural geology of continental
shelves?
For Australia, with a large continental shelf
and a dozen tiny neighbors, the answer was
obvious.
And so, after U.S. President Harry Truman
set the precedent by taking the latter approach,
Australia saw its golden opportunity to do
likewise.
But it would soon find something far more
profitable than oysters.
Having unilaterally claimed ownership of this
entire region — which came as close as 30
miles to the Timor coast — it began confidently
searching for oil.
By 1965, Australia had issued exploration
permits to Woodside, Shell, ARCO, and several
others for areas far closer to Indonesia than
its own land borders.
The two countries then reached a border agreement
that heavily favored Australia.
But that still left a giant question mark
over this area.
East Timor was then a Portuguese colony, whom
Australia refused to negotiate with.
Instead, it waited.
And, in 1975, Indonesia solved this problem
for Australia by invading Portuguese Timor.
It sat by as up to 200,000 people were killed.
In 1989, they reached an agreement that split
the gap into three zones — one in which
oil revenue would be shared equally, and two
in which one country was entitled to 90%.
Minus the protests at home, it went exactly
as Australia had hoped.
These boundaries even remained after Timor-Leste
became independent 13 years later, except
that the new country was now entitled to 90%
of revenue from the shared zone, rather than
just half.
Its people had no say during Portuguese colonial
times, were represented by Indonesian occupiers
for the next 25 years, and even after independence,
only inherited the previous agreement.
But it still had not yet seen the full-lengths
Australia would go to steal its oil.
In 2006, the two governments signed a new
agreement that essentially postponed the topic
of maritime boundaries in the interest of
just getting drilling.
The profits from the Greater Sunrise field,
the crown jewel, remember, would now be split
50/50.
6 years later, the world learned some shocking
news.
During the negotiations, the Australian Secret
Service had planted hidden listening devices
near the office of Timor-Leste’s Prime Minister.
Even after word got out, it refused to invalidate
the treaty.
Only in 2018, after bringing the case to the
International Court of Justice, did they finally
resolve the dispute.
Under the new agreement, Timor-Leste will
get 70% of the revenue if the oil is piped
to its shores, and 80% if it flows through
Australia.
In 2019, the country spent $650 million in
public funds to buy a controlling stake in
the oil field.
After nearly half a century of waiting, Timor-Leste
finally regained control of its own destiny.
But it may have been too late.
Australia’s negotiating strategy, apart
from outright bullying, was always to delay.
Unlike its neighbor, it didn’t need the
money urgently and knew time was on its side.
Now, today, with fossil fuels slowly on the
way out and as oil prices plummeted during
the pandemic, Timor-Leste finds itself in
a dilemma:
On one hand, it could learn the lesson of
other oil-dependent nations and process the
oil and gas onshore — creating new jobs
and hopefully growing the overall economy.
But independent analysts say, at 70%, accounting
for the cost to build the infrastructure,
it would only break even.
After all that work, it wouldn’t even make
money.
In fact, the project is so economically questionable
that even China — famous for its “debt-trap
diplomacy” — refused to fund it.
On the other hand, it could instead pipe the
oil to Australia, in which case it would receive
80% of the revenue.
But in that case, it would eventually return
right back where it started — with no new
jobs or economic activity.
The Tasi-Mane project has been ridiculed as
a “White Elephant”.
Its four-lane “superhighway” literally
crumbling apart and its pristine yet empty
airport have all the hallmarks of irresponsible
populace-pleasing spending.
Still, the question remains: What should it
do to escape its state of poverty?
The unfortunate truth is that: there may not
be a good answer.
The reason for Timor Leste’s troubles ultimately
comes down to maritime border ambiguities.
Throughout history, the sea has been divided
by doing everything from drawing a line right
down the middle, to measuring the distance
a cannon could shoot from shore.
We explore this question in more depth in
this exclusive bonus video on Nebula called
“Who owns the ocean?”.
Nebula is home to other PolyMatter bonus videos,
entirely exclusive Nebula Originals from other
great channels, plus ad-free and early access.
You can get Nebula and CuriosityStream for
just $15/year.
I recently watched this great CuriosityStream
documentary on Brunei — another tiny oil-dependent
country not far from Timor-Leste.
But Brunei is one of the last true absolute
monarchies, ruled by a sultan.
It explores the question: How will it survive
when it eventually runs out of oil?
Click the link on screen right now to get
both Nebula and CuriosityStream for just over
a dollar a month and go watch the bonus video
over on Nebula.